みなさんこんにちは建築家の鈴木亜生です
私は東京に事務所があっていろんな地域で仕事をしています
今日は
この路面電車に乗って会場に行きました
芝が軌道敷の芝が合うとして
真知宇ロイを与えていてとても心地いいですよね
皆さんはこの芝の下に何が敷かれているかご存知ですか
ちょっと何をなにがしかというかご存知な方
手をあげていただきいいですか
意外とあの鹿児島の方も知らない方が多いんですが
実はこのシラスを使ったブロック悪しかれているんです
しらすの粒の隙間に芝が根をはり
しらすが含んだ水をしバスって
青は他車種アン芝が生育できるんです
エコをきっかけにしてこうした新しい心地よさが
町生まれてくるんですね
昨年私が鹿児島にこのシラスのブロックを使って作ったエコハウスを通して今日は
エコと新しい心地よさについて皆さんと考えていきたいとおもいます
こちらが今日の主役の方です
このカップとの出会いは私が沖縄でリゾートホテルは設計している時でした
この形は
沖縄の暑い環境でも
エアコンを設けず
沖縄の海風に吹かれながら
庭には版を育てるのを楽しんでいいました
そして後今日のこの鹿児島に戻り同じようにエアコンのない生活を楽しみたいという
要望を私は受けました
最初はとても驚きました
だって皆さんよく考えてみてください
建築はまず外部の環境と切り離して
エアコンで人にとっての快適な温度を保つということが前提となっていますよね
それをのエアコンの力を借りずして人に心地よい環境を作り出してくださいという依頼
なんです
私はこれは新しい建築を作り出す者チャンスだと思いました
そして
それによって新しい心地よさが生まれてくるくるはずだと考えました
それてそれは
今私たち
環境負荷低減の行2した課題を抱える中で
今多くの設備機器が新しい急速に
貼って開発されています
ただその省エネが
賞は省エネが
要求される中では
負荷は大きく負担になり
提言は
松園の提言はどんどん付買う
その荘園を負荷はどんどん待つばかりで
その限界は
にはあの
限界に追い上げますその
限界は
財布メンズ限界はあると思います
心地よさのこれまでの私たちの
基準は
機能性や
利便性というものが
基準になってきたように思います
ですからそういった
設備の効率というものはどんどん
負担になってくるはずです
ただこの心地よさの基準というものが変わっていけば
我慢のショーへというものが
続かないのではないかと考えました
そして私はこうお客さんに提案したんです
エコを楽しむ間を作りましょう
これは高い断熱性を持っによって外部と切り離し
松園の危機を
多く搭載したエコハウスではありません
エコー楽しみ新しい心地よさのま多く作ろうという平安です
そこでこの家のテーマが決まりました
白砂によって心地よさの基準を変えるです
もともとエコノ
エコはエコロジーの役で
生態系の
構造と
機能を明らかにするという言葉です
鹿児島の形態生態を支えているのは
しらすの地質や
地形であります
しらすが地形を生み
作り
風を生み食物を育み
人に恵みを与えています
敷地はこのシラス台地の上にある住宅地です
このシラスの力を使った家をつくりました
アイラカールでらー
一帯に広がる
シラスは糧にすると3500立方メートル
東京ドーム約28万倍も号の糧になると言われています
多くの実装 a
実質の特徴は多くの他の地質にはない
多くの特徴を持っています
では
それがなぜ実用化されてこなかったのでしょうか
コンクリートは砂や砂利
を利用し
セメントと水を化学反応させて共同を作っています
その砂や砂利にの代わりにしらすを利用するに
にはシラスが多くの決定を持っているため強度をつくることができなかったんです
ただある鹿児島のブロックメーカーが
これまでの水と白セメントを混ぜるのではなく
この200トンのプレス機を開発してシラスが水を含んでいるということを利用して
圧縮することで白住むが見ず知らずが含んでいる
水がにじみ出るですね
そうするとセメントと圧着することで強度が出ることになったんです
そしてここにあるブロックが完成しました
これが今皆さんが歩いているデーモン彼に今細
舗装されています
あるいは
今日皆さんが利用している自然の下に惹かれている
細芝の下に惹かれている舗装ブロックです
まあこれを私が鹿児島に最初に来たときに
この舗装ブロックが建物内部の
断熱性
に行けると考え
このブロックメーカーと今回共同開発して原地区材料に応用しエコハウスを作ったわけ
です
これがその家の心地よさを作るためにしやすいになってもらっている
心地よさの機能です
外壁と内壁を二重にして積み上げ
その間には空気層を設け断熱精度を増しています
屋上には路面電車と同じ芝を引いています
内壁にはシラスの原石を砕かずそのまま
埋め込み
+高温多湿な鹿児島で湿気を
夏には九州市
吹いがその水分を放出する役割を担っています
こうして散らすが壁屋根全体にとりかく3
エアコンのない家において建物しらす自体が a あコンディション
してくれるような機能になっています
ここからが家づくりのスタートです
しらすといっても鹿児島の方でも身近にする機会はないと思います
大隅半島にあるシラスの採掘場に行きお客さんと行き
しらすを実際に
採掘師
手に触れどのような重さかどのような表情をしているか確認しこの
穴に入って
温度室と実感してもらいました
そして洞窟に入って実際に知らずの原石を採掘する作業です
まあ見ていただくとおとうさんが一番あのため思想に彫っているんですね
まあこれが入ったのはクリスマス e 9なんですけど
まあなかなかそんな姫ですね言ってくれる子が使わないかもしれないんですけど
まあこういったシラスの採掘掘り起こす作業ですが私たち眠っている
心地よさの感覚を掘り起こすような作業でもあったと思います
その原石を実際にこれからブロックでに工場で歩6分
製造する作業です
普段は工場のラインで大量生産する
できることですが初めてここでは一つ一つ
原石をパレットに並べていく作業です
これだけ大変な
って作業ですが
神の普段は人工石が
天然石のような素晴らしいブロックになりました
実際にできたブロックがこのこのブロックです
まあしらすの2万5000年の
堆積した時間がまあこういった
表情にカップされた表情になっています
ここに埋まっているのはシラスの原石です
お酒多孔質な表情になっています
そして出来上がった家がこれです
しらすの
第一を
崖をイメージした
台形型の
形をしています地域の方々から
団欒に積まれた表情を見てピラミッドと相性を呼ばれているんですが私が作品名を
付ける前にもそういう愛称で呼んでいただいています
まあそのそのこっちの
堆積岩を使って積み上げているっていう点ではシラスと
ピラミット同じかもしれません
さあここから生活が始まりシラスによって新しい心地よさ
について説明していきます
家の生活の中心リビングですが
一般的なライフスタイルを
について考えていけば普段普通はソファーが置かれ
指が並び
指定は居場所が決まり姿勢が決まっていくと思いますがここではそういったソファ
テレビは並ばず
床に寝転び b
思い思いの場所で生活しています
この試合が鹿児島産のフローリングを使って
その床に触れているのは心地いいからなんです
左の和室上にはにか屋上に上がるテラスがあって
この livin から大きな開口通して
空を見えるんですね
満月の夜にはここに家族で布団を並べて皆で語り合いそう
語り合うそうです
同じリビングでは
このピアノ弾くとここが快適な音楽ホールでだったことを気づかされます
このい鉛会館もそうですが
穴あきの吸音ボードという種素材で仕上げられています
しらすブロッカー多孔質な穴を穴を
がいくつも開いているように
その吸音ボードの機能のか中昨日に変わる訳あるようになっています
壁が2重壁で防音性が高いため
隣の家を気にせず演奏が楽しめると
オナー子も喜んでくれています
右側の写真では
バスケットボールゴールが取り付けられ
まあこのようなリビングが遊び土間に変わってしまっています
こういった遊びの場機能を
見つけるのもこのお客さんは得意なんですねー
まあ屋上はやめ雨水をためると例のような役割はになっていて
その薄いが問いを通して
海やゴミをロロ化してこの庭にある
雨水タンクに200リットルまで食べられます
その水は
戦車散水に
庭の散水に
利用されて子どもたちは雨が降るのを待ち望んでいます
壁にはあの子の小学生の娘さんがボルダリングがようにして上まで登っていってしまう
んですが
この壁には集まってくるのはあの女の子だけじゃなくて
まぁ買うか5章の皆さんにはあのご存知の通り
桜島の降灰がまあ集まってきてくれるというか
まあそういったあのまあ迷惑なものが集まってくるっていうのはあの壁を汚してしまう
ものではなくて
壁にとってはまあお化粧のように
このシラスブロックにとっては仲間のような存在なので
そういったあの深みを都市が取るにつれてシラスブロックの表情を深みを与えてくれる
まあお化粧ではなくそのアンチエイジングではなくエイジングの効果を与えてくれる
しらすの心地よさと言っていいかもしれません
屋上に登れば
街のシラス台地の街が波が広がり
桜島まで一望できます
シラス台地と近郊案が作り出す海陸風という本土地特有の局地風が
桜島から吹き上がってくるのはここで肌で実感できるんです
この屋根に登れば家の境界線という意識が消え
自然と
街と一体であることを実感させてくれます
ここまでこの心地よさによって
新しい
こちらさの基準が生まれてくることを見てきましたがあ
皆さんにとって心地よさの基準は
何でしょうか
私はあの子の心地仕事を通して
エコをきっかけに心地よさの基準が少しずつ確実に変わりつつあることを実感しました
この環境の時代の中で
エコをきっかけにさまざまな分野で
あらゆる発見が出来るかと思います
これまで
日の目を見て来なかったものや
昨日は
定められてきてしまったもの
無駄だと思われてきてしまったものをそういったものを再評価することで
新しい心地よさ新しい楽しみ方
そういったものが
生まれてくるはずだと考えます
今日皆さんも
帰りこのかえり
4でに乗って
しらすの心地よさに触れながら
皆さんの目指すあ
分野で
ご自分たちが
楽しんでみたい
作り出してみたい
そう思う
中で
どんな心地よさは生まれてくるだろう
そんな
思いに触れながらいろんな考えを生み出してみてはいかがでしょうか
ご静聴ありがとうございました